hello I'm bored I practiced my question
so many times that I lost my voice
that's amazing first of all I would like
to thank you because I started my career
as an entrepreneur by trying to build
the next Facebook but thanks to your
speeches on self-awareness I I came to
realize that I lose sleep over borrowing
hundred euros from my brother so you
know I probably will never build the
next Facebook that's having that in mind
so a year ago I started to build a data
migration company you know organically
so I landed a big customer and now I get
paid every day and I'm developing my
stuff and we went live in production in
Chile in December and this year for the
same company we will do USA Mexico and
Canada so it's going really great but my
question to you was you talked a lot
about patience so but you also talk
sometimes about speed and patience for
me that would be you know continue with
the same but the ones they answer you
real fast you understand it forever ok
macro patience micro speed yeah ok ok
let me expand on it because I'm gonna
work [ __ ] no hold on hold on hold on
back back back
macro patience you're young man building
something meaningful a relationship a
business it takes 10 20 30 years on your
day-to-day work you have to be fast with
the clients they email you you email
them back like your day to day but your
vision what you want to achieve in life
you're not going to build it in one year
and so many people have it reversed in
the day to day they're slow and then the
macro they want their business to be
huge the next day so you need to reverse
it so if you have to make the decision
between in my case building a better
framework or focusing on that or trying
to find more customers what would you
what will you ever advice knowing that I
don't need the money of new code
mr. right now both okay and so and so
here's another here's an answer of both
number one how hard are you working.i
don't know if you're working one twelve
hours a day I feel like you could work
seventeen if you want right number two
if you're working every hour and you
can't work more with the money that's
coming in too many young people and too
many young businesses when they start
having money come in take it for
themselves they want to buy a good watch
they want to buy a good car
they want to buy fancier shoes what I
would do is when my first money so
here's my story this is not advice I'm
giving just for fun this is my life I
walked in my dad's store it did three
million dollars a year ten percent gross
profit $300,000 in profit before
expenses we had no money I was making
$40,000 a year thirty seven four
actually and I built that business from
three to forty five million in the first
kind of four or five years and five
years later five years later this is
doing forty five million dollars in
sales and I'm making $40,000 this is the
advice I gave and by the way I was in my
20s and a guy the exact time if you're
making that kind of money that you want
to use it to do guy things right I put
it back into the business
I hired four more managers six more
managers seven more Mainers I did more
advertising I built a business so if
this money is coming from Chile in the
US and Mexico hire people and you can do
both okay thanks welcome
[Music]